Caption: thank you everyone thank you so much for
Caption: hanging around at the end of a very long
Caption: day thank you to the organizing you to
Caption: seeing on those amazing sponsors there
Caption: who put this day together as you heard I
Caption: do this professionally and for
Caption: volunteers you guys have absolutely
Caption: blown me away like that that's really
Caption: great for those who haven't met me yet
Caption: if you're here my name's Chris
Caption: despite the accent I have lived in this
Caption: country for 16 years now my region from
Caption: the US that didn't suit me I've been
Caption: working in tech for longer than that I
Caption: was a developer I was a business analyst
Caption: I was a people leader I've worked in
Caption: companies like Epson Caroline canva and
Caption: narrower for ya and locally video games
Caption: perfectly regularly which is great
Caption: because you guys there's such a vibrant
Caption: deaf community I have been here three
Caption: days on this trip and I've already been
Caption: to two different Minos including the new
Caption: junior detonator who's just launched so
Caption: if you haven't checked that out please -
Caption: it was really great I loved seeing as
Caption: you do you need this is the first one
Caption: I've ever been to much less spoken at so
Caption: congratulations first and it's been
Caption: fantastic I've been tweeting a storm
Caption: I'm wet but underscore gotta see if you
Caption: want to tweet me during this but then
Caption: you guys all enjoyed yourself
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: inspired well I'm gonna tax your brain
Caption: too much here because I know you have a
Caption: lot to think about so I want to seduce a
Caption: little thought exercise just imagine
Caption: that we're going to go for a nice walk
Caption: together a nice fatty block we're
Caption: friends were like a little or ramble in
Caption: the bush you know the sky is blue the
Caption: trees are green the birds are speeding
Caption: and that even is easy very vivid for me
Caption: because I just come back from holiday
Caption: where I was lucky enough to spend some
Caption: time in the u.s. with my family on
Caption: vacation in Yellowstone National Park
Caption: and folks here it was practically like I
Caption: took that photo I look like a
Caption: three-year-old iPhone and it's still
Caption: just that gorgeous if you've never heard
Caption: of the Yellowstone me it's in the state
Caption: of Wyoming I mean us about 150 years old
Caption: the next one it was the first national
Caption: park in America the first national park
Caption: in the world and was famous for being
Caption: the strength of the largest supervolcano
Caption: on the North American continent it's
Caption: back to my dad reminded us of like every
Caption: 15 minutes and because of the cold air
Caption: it's that really cool geothermal
Caption: features you know it's got mud pots to
Caption: them
Caption: grants is not extremely hiked up to see
Caption: and the Old Faithful geyser
Caption: really go up live like new sub tears and
Caption: moose and coyotes and bald eagles
Caption: so many bison so they bison and like I
Caption: said pristine beautiful and after like a
Caption: day I felt I was come here a little bit
Caption: like I can tell you I could honestly
Caption: count on one hand the number of pieces
Caption: of litter the next on Yellowstone and I
Caption: looked it up there were four million
Caption: people visited that Park last year okay
Caption: so how does it look that way how does it
Caption: been so
Caption: reserved for us to visit I don't think
Caption: the National Park Service has like
Caption: McCartney and employees who come out at
Caption: night like who believe us you know like
Caption: Disneyland's and clean it up they they
Caption: just don't have the budget especially
Caption: not under current administration about
Caption: how does this happen and finding a user
Caption: hurts me in aleppo it's because of a
Caption: real active group effort on the part of
Caption: everybody's business there everybody who
Caption: goes there to keep the park looking the
Caption: way that it does and I realized it's the
Caption: campsite rule literally in action hey
Caption: that's titled my talk with it so do with
Caption: this guy the floor debating health and
Caption: he started the scouts movement back in
Caption: the early 20th century and his last
Caption: letter to the organization in 1941
Caption: you gave them a bit of advice which is
Caption: served and pass down and stab you or as
Caption: part of their core values and that
Caption: advice is this leave this world a little
Caption: better than you found it
Caption: it's very simple it's been come to be
Caption: known as the campsite roll or boys gotta
Caption: look like a fertilized egg roll and
Caption: actually replied to other two names so
Caption: some of you may know that it applies to
Caption: computer programming and she does her
Caption: name on kabamaru who cannot just read
Caption: less than their next meeting out in his
Caption: local clean Co he said what if any time
Caption: you checked out a nozzle because if she
Caption: doesn't air is going out any time you
Caption: checked out a module your company's code
Caption: you imprinted
Caption: checked it back yet and then I didn't
Caption: like it was making perfect you just have
Caption: to make it a little bit of that you know
Caption: refactor something change the name of
Caption: the variable to be something better
Caption: imagine your code then your whole tools
Caption: hub would continually improve it
Caption: wouldn't deteriorate this is how teams
Caption: get better and he actually likens it to
Caption: common decency
Caption: he said deleting the code base messy
Caption: should be associate unacceptable as
Caption: literally fairly like that now those of
Caption: them applied to human relationships the
Caption: columnist dan Savage has said that if
Caption: you're in a relationship where you have
Caption: a more experienced person it is your
Caption: moral responsibility to make sure that
Caption: the less experienced person comes out of
Caption: their relationship physically
Caption: emotionally in as whom the state as they
Caption: women if not better which is really nice
Caption: trigger now in terms of you great
Caption: outdoors it's pretty obvious it means
Caption: things like Tremblay check out the stuff
Caption: you brought in with you make sure you
Caption: don't leave anything behind
Caption: clean the campground and the cool thing
Caption: wasn't yells - like everyone ever seen
Caption: it written anywhere like it wasn't like
Caption: the harsh way we drove into the park you
Caption: know I just kind of picked up on it like
Caption: it like the robot says it's common
Caption: decency but it's a little bit on the
Caption: ground
Caption: I should picked it up and put it in the
Caption: bin nobody had to tell me to do that and
Caption: I can see other people doing it too I
Caption: mean damn sure my family
Caption: and that made me feel good he actually
Caption: made me feel part of something bigger
Caption: like I was part of the grand addition of
Caption: all the people who visited that
Caption: beautiful environment and who work
Caption: together to keep it that way so I have a
Caption: lovely lovely be off line and I didn't
Caption: offline like they don't have Wi-Fi
Caption: there's very little self-service our
Caption: cabinets and even have tvs those you
Caption: don't know
Caption: so Serena's just nature and sleeping and
Caption: food and it was great I'm so rested at
Caption: last and I needed that because when I
Caption: got back Justin I didn't you what I'll
Caption: do
Caption: I turn to my phone my laptop and reality
Caption: came crashing that game in the
Caption: hemisphere that you spend a lot of time
Caption: online these days your mental health
Caption: will suffer you know it can be
Caption: depressing it's it's an inner fire like
Caption: every single day and actually those of
Caption: us working in tech have it worse than
Caption: other people because it's harder for us
Caption: to escape you know the internet is where
Caption: we make our living
Caption: there's some of us devoting significant
Caption: portions of their working life to
Caption: creating this thing and something is
Caption: that thing you really suck my does
Caption: anybody else flinch when I get
Caption: underneath this one was just last week
Caption: I mean Detroit my national treasure we
Caption: can all the great but I am so sick of
Caption: get these emails on your subject of
Caption: crappy insecure websites you know with
Caption: bad security
Caption: whether through laziness or confidence
Caption: I'm tired of box and black hats of
Caption: foreign actors who are you know
Caption: maliciously going after our data trying
Caption: to compromise our information did you
Caption: can see the news about the Equifax data
Caption: breach last week in the u.s. a hundred
Caption: and forty three million people had their
Caption: personal data compromised
Caption: nearly half the population of the US and
Caption: a little certainly including me
Caption: and then there's IOT you know I don't
Caption: eat where the S stands for security
Caption: you know we had a gal talk just a few
Caption: months ago Chris he's told me a story
Caption: there was a casino in the US that that
Caption: packs to its Wi-Fi enabled fish tank
Caption: [Music]
Caption: like it's bad enough I have to worry my
Caption: dishwasher has a directory traversal but
Caption: not to fire my fishnet security is like
Caption: an arms race these days and a lot of the
Caption: time it feels like we're losing and then
Caption: there's Silicon Valley you know which is
Caption: supposed to be the pinnacle of our
Caption: industry is this shining epitome of
Caption: everything we ever hear to be striving
Caption: to be right where the brightest minds of
Caption: our generation are reinventing the
Caption: public bus that you know without poor
Caption: people and slugging 400 on Wi-Fi table
Caption: juicers yeah he closed the company down
Caption: recently but 119 million dollars in
Caption: funding just two days ago I had to
Caption: update this talk a new startup called
Caption: Luganda launched any us in Thunder
Caption: Valley with the goal of replacing
Caption: mom-and-pop corner stores with
Caption: essentially vending machines because
Caption: that's a target right for disruption
Caption: locally owned small businesses
Caption: you know while they're talking to an
Caption: actual human being when you can just
Caption: grab your bottle of soy left from the
Caption: glorified minibar I have taken that like
Caption: I said somebody on Twitter refer to it
Caption: as bro Ganga the founders of course are
Caption: massively backpedaling this is a pattern
Caption: that we see over and over again in
Caption: Silicon Valley there is always a
Caption: technical solution no matter what the
Caption: structural problem no matter what the
Caption: human consequences are but the news the
Caption: news is really what makes they want to
Caption: just burn it all down there are
Caption: literally Nazis burn Pepe the Frog goons
Caption: using the internet but we all helped
Caption: create to create protests in towns that
Caption: look like the one that I grew up in up
Caption: until yesterday
Caption: Facebook's algorithms living target ads
Caption: to into submitting groups and we only
Caption: suggest be throwing the gun nuts why are
Caption: there the current US administration is
Caption: doing everything he can to roll back net
Caption: neutrality just strict health care for
Caption: millions of people and to enshrine
Caption: religious discrimination as immigration
Caption: policy although the president Traxxas
Caption: our World War 3 on Twitter and near in
Caption: Australia it's not like we can escape it
Caption: we've got the NBN debacle driving on
Caption: directly here we've got every day I'll
Caption: remember part of it was I'm a dual
Caption: citizen and now the vicious campaign
Caption: we're seeing over the postal feticide
Caption: excuse me non-binding postal survey who
Caption: didn't none of us actually wanted in the
Caption: first place and then if it's a really
Caption: good day I get to read a manifesto about
Caption: no one
Caption: we unfit to work in the industry I've
Caption: spent the last 20 years in friends these
Caption: are the dark days but I'm gonna put
Caption: everything at become Amish this is the
Caption: tech industry I devoted my entire
Caption: working life to and some days I really
Caption: don't like messy feeling I just get it
Caption: at him considering I promise you a
Caption: gentle walk and a chapter and let's be
Caption: clear I can you know use alliterative
Caption: harder bumping and fixing all of that is
Caption: entirely another like cleaning up the
Caption: issues in the tech industry is no small
Caption: thing there is no good solution I am NOT
Caption: gonna stand here and try to tell you
Caption: personally to Judy and about that stuff
Caption: although if you can please do you know
Caption: right for secure websites build
Caption: algorithms that don't encode
Caption: discrimination support diversity
Caption: programs punch a Nazi you know
Caption: but the bigger issue as I see it is the
Caption: suicide illogical cold at pile of litter
Caption: teams on us you know it's just there
Caption: every day we open our computers a
Caption: reminder of how far this industry is
Caption: from the awesome place that we all know
Caption: that it can be and that can make you
Caption: feel helpless and depressed it can make
Caption: you it can make you feel really stressed
Caption: and if your job is already stressful
Caption: that is a recipe that leads to burnout
Caption: so people how many of you would say if
Caption: you have burnt out and once I went there
Caption: in your career for whatever value of
Caption: burnt out that's what I thought I have
Caption: done there to either the industry for a
Caption: couple years in fact before I come back
Caption: I have plenty of other people who've
Caption: been in the other and then employee
Caption: people who stayed in to the toll on
Caption: their health and other relationships
Caption: when new people in this industry leave
Caption: we all suffer we cannot fix those
Caption: problems without everybody we need
Caption: everybody in and at the top of their
Caption: game so how do you stave off burnout how
Caption: do you stay motivated and energized in
Caption: the face of that mountain of litter you
Caption: know how do i hopefully talked about
Caption: some strategies for the prettier top
Caption: earlier and i'm going to talk you
Caption: through some of the ones that work for
Caption: me personally they wouldn't sleep most
Caption: of us don't get enough sleep it was a
Caption: fantastic talk a few months back from
Caption: melbourne my jamie skele the
Caption: productivity met and as long as you
Caption: should look it up and he quoted a
Caption: neuroscientist
Caption: and sleep is the single most effective
Caption: things you can do to reset your brain
Caption: and body so please everybody came to an
Caption: exercise you can physically get away
Caption: like I did you know combination it works
Caption: but it's not cheap and most of us are
Caption: limited in how often ended up you can
Caption: participate in tech events like this I
Caption: find the feeling part of the community
Caption: really makes me feel a sense of purpose
Caption: and unfortunate now because of my job of
Caption: the ow that's basically my job you know
Caption: a couple weeks out of the year I get to
Caption: spend time with some of the nicest
Caption: smartest people in history people like
Caption: Berto you know but again I get that
Caption: that's difficult not everybody lives in
Caption: a place that has you know meetups
Caption: happening all the time now that your
Caption: buddy has a family situation when they
Caption: can get away go to conferences or a
Caption: meet-up second honey
Caption: you may have a lower tolerance for
Caption: eating pizza here at every you know what
Caption: I do you never been a passion project or
Caption: hobby
Caption: weather tech there otherwise I have a
Caption: fan website for the children's off
Caption: they're all dull for notion 20 years now
Caption: I also knit and so is your turn which
Caption: gets me away from the keyboard maybe
Caption: you're into video games or sandwiches on
Caption: Jamie's bedspread you know you went to
Caption: CrossFit or I worked on an open source
Caption: project all of that stuff can be your
Caption: release spells it can be a way for you
Caption: to relax away from the tensions of your
Caption: day job and it's one last one which is
Caption: the thing I'm going to talk the most
Caption: about here at my talk today because it's
Caption: been the single biggest source of
Caption: happiness and satisfaction for me in my
Caption: career in the industry for the last few
Caption: years and that thing is mentoring so all
Caption: that other stuff is great for you
Caption: personally it'll help you feel better
Caption: for your health your well-being
Caption: but mentoring has the added benefit of
Caption: actually improving the industry it's how
Caption: you been
Caption: insight into action right now and that's
Caption: how you have so again there's another
Caption: cold here how many of you would say to
Caption: you have a mentor okay how do you want
Caption: to network yeah and none of you are a
Caption: mentor okay and whenever I talk about
Caption: mentoring the response I get is that
Caption: very few people think they're qualified
Caption: to be members almost everybody wants one
Caption: but nobody knows how to actually get one
Caption: so what I'm going to tell you how today
Caption: my older remainder of this talk is
Caption: futile leave with some concrete
Caption: vegetable steps to get yourself involved
Caption: with mentoring and the certainly minty
Caption: sighs it seems like there were more
Caption: people who work or looking for a mentor
Caption: now like many of you this is the image I
Caption: have adventuring up till few years ago
Caption: you know this wise sage on the
Caption: mountaintop that we've dispensed mister
Caption: will tell you what to do in your career
Caption: and of course everybody wants out like
Caption: who put them in that's the minute that I
Caption: want to discuss because managers come in
Caption: a lot of different shapes and sizes and
Caption: you probably have several right now in
Caption: your life who don't even realize it so
Caption: this is why I came from aluminum code
Caption: Singapore meetup I went to earlier this
Caption: year we were having a discussion about
Caption: ventures and how to find them we started
Caption: by the visiting everything you could
Caption: think of that mentors did and sort of
Caption: categorizing would you put a lot of
Caption: different things so sometimes those are
Caption: just there to inspire review you know
Caption: look like a role model it might be
Caption: someone like boy though we've seen an
Caption: event that is written that booked in
Caption: love and they just provided a vision for
Caption: your career that you want it anyway
Caption: you know them there are ministers give
Caption: you career values and that's probably
Caption: the closest to that stage on the
Caption: mountains how I'm dealing you know
Caption: that's someone in the industry who's bad
Caption: manner you know they can probably see
Caption: the big picture
Caption: hope you make actionable steps to get
Caption: where you want to go in your career and
Caption: provide accountability on getting there
Caption: they're also members who help you with
Caption: the day-to-day aspects of your job
Caption: we called them tech mentors here but I
Caption: think a better name is probably the
Caption: coaches you know it doesn't necessarily
Caption: have to be tapped this could be someone
Caption: that you pair programmer it could be you
Caption: know a senior developer in your company
Caption: maybe an old colleague in the industry
Caption: you catch up with them out then if you
Caption: share you know advice and ask questions
Caption: you even even give slack community and I
Caption: think that's not the cut community here
Caption: in Perth is a great example of this some
Caption: ministers go above and beyond just
Caption: giving you advice
Caption: they actually advocate on your behalf
Caption: and we've called the champions
Caption: I'm also heard the term sponsors and
Caption: these are fantastic is this someone who
Caption: not just will give you some tips but
Caption: will actively suggest you for roles and
Caption: give you referrals interacts with it
Caption: right and lastly there are your peers
Caption: and people always discount peers and you
Caption: know you shouldn't like your friends
Caption: your colleagues and people on your team
Caption: the people around you at this event are
Caption: your peers they share your frustrations
Caption: and you can talk to them and get advice
Caption: and ideas
Caption: now the cool thing is there is no limits
Caption: how many measures you can have and you
Caption: can have members from all these
Caption: different nerves you probably have some
Caption: now and sometimes even a single person
Caption: can fulfill multiple walls here it's
Caption: okay it's still want to have a formal
Caption: mentor though you know son you can
Caption: actually point to and say that's my
Caption: network so I have I've had a formal
Caption: mentor for body here now we need up
Caption: every month or so to talk about like
Caption: current challenges I'm facing questions
Caption: and
Caption: you know how to get to the next stage
Caption: right there is stuff like that so how do
Caption: you get one there are few different ways
Caption: community if your company has a
Caption: mentoring program take advantage of it
Caption: like what does most people think once
Caption: you do a but you should you know I tell
Caption: you get carried out with someone outside
Caption: of your reporting lines if you don't
Caption: want to be somebody you know report to
Caption: but if you have only in your office
Caption: Julia there are also external mentoring
Caption: programs you know maybe your university
Caption: alumni first off there's learning check
Caption: we've done a lot of them do their own
Caption: industry bodies I know ACS has a
Caption: mentoring program if you're in one of
Caption: the people initiative think ask sandy
Caption: has a mentorship program there are
Caption: several there your LinkedIn group I
Caption: believe you do this there are also some
Caption: private bodies who do it I know that
Caption: there's a group ladies called Metro box
Caption: sadly nothing perfect yet but in other
Caption: Australian cities really a carer for the
Caption: Metro you go for walks together and it's
Caption: also a company if I'm cold otherwise
Caption: that actually provide again corporate
Caption: enterprise matchmaker they also do you
Caption: also just volunteer to be a mentor again
Caption: eventually them to or because you can
Caption: just ask somebody and that is the
Caption: hardest one by far so I'm gonna tell you
Caption: the story of how about I got my mentor
Caption: so my mentor is someone that I saw speak
Caption: at a tech event about five years ago and
Caption: they just went straight into met like a
Caption: inspiring bucket I was just like oh my
Caption: god I want to be her my girl up you know
Caption: like her career
Caption: clearly really smart very confident knew
Caption: what she was doing seemed like someone
Caption: who we have all the answers and I just
Caption: so the girl so it kind of just stopped I
Caption: couldn't even get an occurrence to like
Caption: talk to her you know a few years later I
Caption: connected whether or not LinkedIn and
Caption: she just might look by this point she
Caption: was a c-level that like that being
Caption: Australian comedy well she's no time for
Caption: me oh my you know there's no way she's
Caption: got time to be on with me unless the
Caption: Waikiki problems and then the 918 once
Caption: ago I was finding a friend of mine and I
Caption: was telling her how their career
Caption: crossroads kind of did you know Ericsson
Caption: is you could really use a network and
Caption: she doesn't know you should talk to you
Caption: should totally talk to this person like
Caption: I all right I'm gonna stop in her for
Caption: years but I like what she's up to
Caption: II like you know and she's like any
Caption: early yet and because I'm gonna give you
Caption: some advice
Caption: and she can mean the best tip it is that
Caption: one rear tip for getting a mentor and I
Caption: know that Cheryl there is what you're
Caption: talkin to do if you me you have some
Caption: relationship with a person you're a
Caption: complete stranger that we use you
Caption: separating them you say hi Ohio
Caption: under this sort of pure crossroads I'm
Caption: looking permanent or right now ideally
Caption: my mentor would have all of these
Caption: categories of course you would be ideal
Caption: but I know that you Julie are so busy in
Caption: your schedule so I really want to know
Caption: if you have five minutes of your time
Caption: where we can get our coffee and you
Caption: could suggest some potential
Caption: and I was like that is genius because it
Caption: gives them an out you know gives them an
Caption: outlet to say and that's why I felt
Caption: embarrassed at making her reject me and
Caption: that got to get away you know so the
Caption: standards like worst-case scenario now
Caption: she has to give me some names of
Caption: potential mentors like that's not too
Caption: bad best-case scenario what happened in
Caption: my case and what I imagine happens in
Caption: most cases is unique with a person and
Caption: then they end up becoming your mentor so
Caption: there you go that is my top tip break my
Caption: only regret is that we didn't accept her
Caption: earlier because she fiction she's gonna
Caption: go through the cabinets that she was
Caption: inspiration now she's been her mentor
Caption: and actually now that we put things up
Caption: book a year she's moved into the sponsor
Caption: stage like she's actually gonna
Caption: referring me and her stuff which is
Caption: fantastic and when I told her how I felt
Caption: like you know too embarrassed to ask her
Caption: for you she was if you're an idiot
Caption: usually a few years ago that's why I
Caption: stopped by
Caption: so once you find one once you find an
Caption: editor I still do mention a few things
Caption: you can do to set yourself up for
Caption: success these are things you often talk
Caption: about the first time you meet with them
Caption: if you want to be really formal about it
Caption: we're actually only internet with formal
Caption: mentoring documents you can
Caption: the first thing is to establish the
Caption: goals the best ninfa conversation I ever
Caption: had was at this table this young guy to
Caption: your developer to walk tell man I'm a
Caption: junior and then this for two years I
Caption: want to be a senior how do I get there
Caption: easy easy we can talk about concrete
Caption: steps to either me Michael's to change
Caption: that was the tricky bit you know when I
Caption: spun first meeting with my mentor losing
Caption: my last role and I was sort of on a
Caption: different path and by the time you met
Caption: again I accepted my love Danielle who's
Caption: Mitch highly changed has actually Center
Caption: I explained the situation as I look I'm
Caption: not necessarily the same clicks we were
Caption: when we agreed to this so if you wanted
Caption: to sort of like call it that's fun
Caption: there's sometimes on the student science
Caption: but it's good to have that it's a very
Caption: clear also be clearing expectations like
Caption: for how you're going to meet up breaking
Caption: up Skype chats you're gonna meet a
Caption: person how frequently and what methods
Caption: of communication or you know if this is
Caption: a certain important person you might
Caption: have to go through be a you know are you
Caption: are you allowed to call them an email
Caption: them you may even want to send an
Caption: you know say that will do this
Caption: relationship for the year that way
Caption: they're not committing or to something
Caption: entirely open-ended and then you can
Caption: sort of review it that's when you should
Caption: be able to respectful of their time you
Caption: know don't be late I'll cancel on the
Caption: last minute don't badger them of
Caption: questions in between sessions I mean
Caption: give you some advice you should follow
Caption: it but when she tells me to do something
Caption: I'm infant no and then usually the next
Caption: time we meet up I'd tell her about how
Caption: they did with that like that's just nice
Caption: and respectful that's what they're there
Caption: for and if they do refer you for
Caption: something realize how great that is
Caption: they're putting their reputation on the
Caption: line for you so you should do everything
Caption: you can to make them look good the end
Caption: of the openness feedback and really let
Caption: go of your ego and this again part that
Caption: I was talking some of the mentors a lot
Caption: of like entrepreneurs it's just painful
Caption: they come in and they give you their
Caption: business idea and you poke holes in it
Caption: and it's just crushing but a minister is
Caption: not about just giving you validation you
Caption: know that's what they're there for
Caption: they're there to actually tell you about
Caption: the whole places this could go wrong so
Caption: you know try to not get too invested in
Caption: them and learn sleep study Genda like
Caption: and once you are in sort of like a big
Caption: corporate program you probably not going
Caption: to have a structured format for these
Caption: exceptions you know and it's retention
Caption: you hold in that trap again I'm just
Caption: speaking them they're don't my stage
Caption: when we was coming how this mentoring
Caption: thing is supposed to work instead you
Caption: have to do it you have to get the most
Caption: out of the relationship
Caption: and since aren't sure there are plenty
Caption: of introverts here who are just cringing
Caption: at the thought of this conversation I'll
Caption: give you some ideas
Caption: is that you can talk about what
Caption: everybody just some different work done
Caption: as we say off the battery you know
Caption: asking about it career path ask some
Caption: other company they work in why they
Caption: chose it but they like it how they spend
Caption: an average day what challenges they've
Caption: faced
Caption: basically it's try to know them as a
Caption: person that knows and trusts if you've
Caption: got concrete career goals like that
Caption: junior engineer don't want to be a
Caption: senior engineer just the steps you can
Caption: take you know are there particular books
Caption: or courses that you should look into
Caption: they'll get you to the next level other
Caption: professional organizations and events
Caption: that you should check out there's a ton
Caption: of events in the efforts they can help
Caption: you filter out the ones they're actually
Caption: good are different people you should
Caption: connect with that's a big one that's
Caption: where you actually start growing your
Caption: networks through them you can ask them
Caption: to review your CV to be really helpful
Caption: you can actually even do a mock
Caption: interview with you know especially if
Caption: you you know you have a particular role
Caption: you're coming for and depending on who
Caption: you are you know you might want to
Caption: document these activities you might want
Caption: to set time your friends and follow up
Caption: on number five ability another thing you
Caption: can do and it's something that I tend to
Caption: do that most of my mentor it's just ask
Caption: for help and advice whatever I'm having
Caption: a problem
Caption: you know maybe look at the landmark work
Caption: or or an opportunity you're considering
Caption: basically lay out the situation and say
Caption: what would you do if you were me
Caption: alright so do some good ideas about like
Caption: what kind of mentors are are how you can
Caption: find
Caption: and the most out of it so now for those
Caption: of you who are a little bit further on
Caption: your career I'm going to talk about the
Caption: flip side actually being mentally came
Caption: to being a mentor by accident and I was
Caption: reading for like a really long time
Caption: before I realized that I was most of my
Caption: mentoring came about through my
Caption: involvement with the city Girl Meets
Caption: inner scrapper I started when this
Caption: meetup 70 years ago it was going to meet
Caption: up get meaner people and eventually you
Caption: know after four years taking the first
Caption: hackathon and they're like hey would you
Caption: mind giving a little talk of how to how
Caption: to pitched your have to know how to do
Caption: the presentation part and that's common
Caption: responses will look like this popping up
Caption: so is necessarily anything but common
Caption: sense I don't consider myself an expert
Caption: on that topic okay so it makes it softer
Caption: people were they flipped out they were
Caption: so nice about it and then guys who have
Caption: to do it every year since so that's
Caption: gonna got me into doing top step and
Caption: then this year to get any questions from
Caption: people in a group you know they can come
Caption: on because you can now provide your
Caption: career Hereward
Caption: this company I'm thinking of going to
Caption: work for this email me send me a general
Caption: eats and then free to people outside the
Caption: room or asking you to lunch
Caption: have a coffee you know get some advice
Caption: on their job or their startup and then
Caption: they just in the last year I've started
Caption: actually plugging in whole groups of
Caption: people have actually given some talks
Caption: with you understand that code Academy
Caption: and talking to people or just
Caption: you sir so what I'm saying is there are
Caption: a lot of different ways to be a mentor
Caption: 'but that aren't like a formal you know
Caption: you are a wise sensei you know you
Caption: probably all remember it right now the
Caption: people when you just don't call it that
Caption: so you want to start down the mentoring
Caption: path i recommend you start small and
Caption: more populated so just generally be
Caption: active in the community you acted in
Caption: your company be generous with your
Caption: knowledge in your time you know make it
Caption: clear that you're open to questions for
Caption: newbies that they can come to you and
Caption: talk to you and you can give them your
Caption: time go to meet us if you can and talk
Caption: to people outside of just your circle of
Caption: friends find the person off on their own
Caption: and talk to them if you can't go to
Caption: meetups consider joining the slack
Caption: community like you know then there's a
Caption: review source or something like that or
Caption: an online community I mean Stack
Caption: Overflow can wear that little it should
Caption: lead to informal mentoring which is just
Caption: people reaching out to you for help you
Caption: know I also heard it called implicit
Caption: mentoring like it's not a big deal
Caption: you're gonna have to call it and read it
Caption: at work it's just helping people it's
Caption: just being nice
Caption: and there's group mentoring which you
Caption: know the easiest step is probably giving
Caption: talks significant in any purse next year
Caption: you know speaking of meetup there are
Caption: also tons of groups who mean technical
Caption: people to help in Sydney we have no
Caption: girls you have perfect girls here that
Caption: are general rules like that those are
Caption: all about getting weather
Caption: I mean you do not have to be an expert
Caption: to help someone who's never met before
Caption: loop okay and it would be an intensely
Caption: bright line I promise you that I've done
Caption: it you can never have to contact us
Caption: trust me sometime phones are sad because
Caption: they don't have enough technical people
Caption: go in join a team and you can really
Caption: help some people out with their
Caption: technical skills they're doing that you
Caption: can offer to speak to students you know
Caption: reach out to your unique I reach out to
Caption: people at GA code Academy could even
Caption: start a study there for drug smuggler
Caption: and then there's formal management if
Caption: you think you're ready to take that step
Caption: again it protected your company a step
Caption: up a program you know put your hand up
Caption: for go straighter University alumni as
Caption: well your students you're in you don't
Caption: just let people know that you're willing
Caption: to do this on the Negroni slack channel
Caption: a year ago we don't live in this one I
Caption: have this my personal caveat is here to
Caption: do some mentoring so I'm willing to take
Caption: on a mentee my expertise is in X Y Z if
Caption: anyone's interested and like ten people
Caption: would there end up immediately she
Caption: hadn't meant even in like five minutes
Caption: and I can tell you from Thursday night
Caption: there are 90 people at the junior Devon
Caption: eat up right now who would love to have
Caption: you as their network go along tell them
Caption: your way okay now I'm going to kind of
Caption: sounds like maybe mentoring a lot of
Caption: work but no but there's actually get a
Caption: lot out of it you know first implements
Caption: unique confidence something what is it
Caption: like 70% of us have an imposter syndrome
Caption: you know I don't know why I'm standing
Caption: up here to find you guys another
Caption: business deal but my talents
Caption: but helping another teaching you know
Caption: things you get more confident in your
Caption: own abilities it's just amazing you do
Caption: perspective on your own problems
Caption: everyone has this tendency to think that
Caption: whatever you're going through is these
Caption: unique you know your company and it's
Caption: not the more you talk to other people
Caption: other companies more you realize that
Caption: it's not going to do everything
Caption: everybody else opposed to the same stuff
Caption: you get better communication skills you
Caption: know when you're you're teaching someone
Caption: who's just starting out but we get good
Caption: at explaining your ideas in different
Caption: ways you have to learn how to have your
Caption: ideas received and understood by the 19
Caption: and that can lead to developing
Caption: leadership skills you know I think a lot
Caption: of tech people are interested in maybe
Caption: looking into a leadership role and
Caption: leadership isn't so much about what you
Caption: do it's about influencing other people
Caption: that communication so mentoring can be a
Caption: really good stepping stone they give you
Caption: an idea of what that actually feels like
Caption: mentoring can give you you know you can
Caption: learn stuff you can give you exposure to
Caption: technology to trends and things that you
Caption: don't actually use in your day job
Caption: you don't want you to pay back that's
Caption: one for me you know I have a lot of
Caption: people help me out with my career when I
Caption: started and it feels really nice to
Caption: actually take that back and pass it
Caption: along and lastly just I think it's human
Caption: beings connecting with other people and
Caption: helping them feels really nice if you
Caption: get a massive buzz when you see someone
Caption: do something that they didn't think of
Caption: ever do so mentoring isn't just
Caption: outsourcing or charity is a two-way
Caption: street you get so much out of it as you
Caption: put into it plus the satisfaction as
Caption: of the camps I've ruled mentoring will
Caption: be an immediate tangible opportunity to
Caption: making industry better and I don't think
Caption: earlier to realize the difference you
Caption: can have the impact you can make right
Caption: now no matter how following your career
Caption: you are and I'm just good we're getting
Caption: entered my travel today I'm gonna give
Caption: you an example of my own experience as a
Caption: mentor to show you exactly what clubs
Caption: across your name
Caption: so earlier this year I was giving a talk
Caption: at coder Academy and sinning and so this
Caption: is a six-month certainty of course these
Caption: people have given up six months their
Caption: lives a lot of money because they want
Caption: so badly to be in this industry and so I
Caption: need to talk to them in Q&A the end and
Caption: this one guy versus Hannity I was at and
Caption: he said how intense is it in using me
Caption: how is it like you know the job like
Caption: yeah it's more intense sometimes another
Caption: so if you've been in this intense thing
Caption: but the Whoopi's is intensive courses
Caption: then he was like you need we don't have
Caption: to code 24/7 and have a side hustle and
Caption: stay up tonight where the world is you
Caption: get that idea
Caption: he says the mentoring about me I was
Caption: arrested my these people wanted so badly
Caption: to be what developers and they were
Caption: already scared and freaked out about the
Caption: stress and demands they can even have
Caption: our jobs here and another mentor
Caption: old that someone had sold them on the
Caption: men that overworking is the only way to
Caption: succeed now we all did that very very
Caption: you know I did that I work 12-hour days
Caption: I sent emails way too late at night I
Caption: don't know anymore collectively moving
Caption: past them um but I guess it's not the
Caption: case just just two days ago my friend
Caption: Mike Sharpe at CityU tweeted a link to
Caption: this job Adam this is a real job that
Caption: read the bold a bit 17 to 19 pounds of
Caption: eight and then you're proud this team is
Caption: proud about driving people to earn it
Caption: it's part of their culture of it you
Caption: know so this myth is not dead just
Caption: getting air in front of that group of
Caption: junior developers I think the only thing
Caption: I could think of a response I told them
Caption: that measure was full of I told
Caption: them that it was a solidary I told them
Caption: that was wrong and they should not
Caption: accept any roles and any companies that
Caption: we expect that you know and obviously if
Caption: I say to any one of them from taking a
Caption: job like this I that makes me very hard
Caption: and that right there is one of the ways
Caption: that I think you can have a major impact
Caption: as a mentor by calling out those
Caption: damaging myths and behaviors that we
Caption: mentor them
Caption: we know her industry energy will work in
Caption: so there's motive myths just briefly the
Caption: one thing you have to be a full-stack
Caption: developer and you have to know
Caption: everything you know Joel Khalifa coined
Caption: the term full-stack anxiety which is the
Caption: stress brought on by companies and
Caption: recruiters who expect to my review
Caption: course you can do everything it's okay
Caption: I recommend he wears many men devote a
Caption: medium post the other technicians found
Caption: it viral when she talked about the idea
Caption: the people who own the grave html/css
Caption: RG value in the industry in favor of
Caption: people who likes outskirts it's really
Caption: good if you don't read it but it's
Caption: perfectly fine to specialize and that
Caption: they take to the next one the content
Caption: culture is acceptable I learned that
Caption: term and Linux comps back in January it
Caption: was a great talk to Lauren Shaw about no
Caption: sense culture content culture that made
Caption: me do where we signal how much we belong
Caption: to the tribe by blaming somebody else by
Caption: putting them down you know how many of
Caption: you have been to a meet up with somebody
Caption: made a joke about PHP you know and
Caption: that's earlier today Nathan you put
Caption: up a PHP is a slide and I just braced
Caption: myself boy and he didn't he didn't he
Caption: actually talks about this as mature
Caption: technology that people have used for in
Caption: our particular students and you know
Caption: already talked about the fact that like
Caption: that's how you learn as a junior
Caption: developer idiot is by putting down other
Caption: people that phone when you make it you
Caption: know that's why he nuts
Caption: tax base whatever you want you know and
Caption: really uttering to people who are
Caption: starting out you know to actually tell
Caption: me you're a real developer you know you
Caption: obviously you know you choose din to use
Caption: that you don't know how
Caption: programmer and see incredibly damaging
Caption: it keeps people out of it puts people
Caption: off you know there is a myth that
Caption: Tinky's a meritocracy you know we want
Caption: to think that we'd like to think that it
Caption: doesn't matter who you are you come from
Caption: anywhere as long as you've got the
Caption: skills you can succeed in this industry
Caption: and therefore the fact that we've all
Caption: succeeded means that we deserve it right
Caption: and that's that's a really dangerous
Caption: road to go down
Caption: you know they've done stuff it's just
Caption: changing the name on a CV can impact
Caption: whether or not that person gets called
Caption: in for an interview there are so many
Caption: other factors that go into whether or
Caption: not you get that same job in the
Caption: industry you should have just assumed
Caption: that a person got there based on pure
Caption: technical merit or the tech narrow is
Caption: the only thing that we look for the
Caption: people that we work with and lastly
Caption: there's that that belief that tech can
Caption: solve every problem you know they get
Caption: that we we like it that's what we like
Caption: to give it their time with it techies
Caption: are a hammer and therefore everything
Caption: looks like a nail
Caption: you know and that leads people to
Caption: thinking these like catacombs are nobody
Caption: to fix homelessness
Caption: you know I have sympathy for that but
Caption: you know I think with comes like social
Caption: issues building in Annapolis and how is
Caption: the best solution and you know it can
Caption: also be to us thinking about visa is so
Caption: much more important than people who
Caption: actually care for others and the beings
Caption: now if you've been in this industry for
Caption: any length of time you know you have any
Caption: tell from the lack that you know how
Caption: damaging these beliefs are you know that
Caption: they eat to the find out that almost all
Caption: of us get up again I've been through so
Caption: without intervention the next generation
Caption: those nineties you hear developers they
Caption: will go through all this the same reason
Caption: I'm mentoring we can break that cycle
Caption: making some people starting out that we
Caption: tried on that stuff and it's crap it
Caption: doesn't work you know we can call out
Caption: companies that like trying to exploit us
Caption: that propped it up these minimally and
Caption: in you know rough prop them up we can
Caption: make this environment this tech industry
Caption: that we loved better for everybody and
Caption: that is my challenge for you all today
Caption: now I haven't wondered pretty far on our
Caption: little walk perhaps the landscape wasn't
Caption: always quite as pretty interconnected as
Caption: I promise moved up to the campsite
Caption: you'll have it applies to different
Caption: domains have working to improve a system
Caption: can be booked the more responsibility
Caption: fell so you can feel really good we've
Caption: talked about ways that the tech industry
Caption: can suck that it can wear it down that
Caption: it can burn you out and then there are
Caption: different strategies everybody can use
Caption: to deal with that you took the
Caption: particular benefits of men
Caption: specifics about how you can get involved
Caption: on both sides of that both sides of that
Caption: practice you do not have to be or look
Caption: for a wide essence' on a mountainside
Caption: all of us can benefit by forming these
Caption: relationships no matter how far you
Caption: aren't your primary and just behind like
Caption: picking up litter in a national park we
Caption: need to call out harmful behaviors
Caption: harmful beliefs what we see them to
Caption: improve the environment both for
Caption: ourselves and the people who come into
Caption: this industry after us I really believe
Caption: the tech industry can be a beautiful
Caption: place if we don't work together to clean
Caption: it up
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you